i think i think one of the uh oh boy one
of the fun things
about doing this show is uh it's getting
to see different youtube personalities
and uh
different people lose their minds and
finding different fandoms now according
to this fandom
the joe rogan's fierce fandom we don't
crush enough
there's there's no crushing for us
um and that of course is your only value
as a human being by the way is how much
you cross yeah dude you got a crush so
we've talked on the show before about
a brennan shop um his little snafu would
you call it a snafu
it's faux pas his faux pas where he uh
was talking about had a guy that
contacted the show both guys going bald
he said brendan you know i like your
respect i look up to you man i need some
advice
going bald and i'm afraid i'm just not
going to do it with the ladies anymore
brandon child proceeded to tell him and
reassure him that don't worry there's
plenty of bald guys out there slinging
dick and he went on to name
dana white joe rogan and then he looked
like
he accidentally killed somebody's baby
that's correct like he just went
like he looked like he made the face
she'd make if if roy said
i just said a baby would you like to
hold it marsh and i literally dropped it
to many yellows
it's the same face they suck they
subsequently
uh started copy uh uh
copyright blocking worldwide anybody
that would have that clip or was even
talking about it
and they took down the episode they took
down the episode and the audio episode
and edited out
that part and put it back up but that
was the end of it brennan then decided
there's more brendan then decided on his
one of his five podcasts the below the
belt
the reason he had a showtime special
podcast um
he went on to say that you know because
i think what happened is they realized
look the cat's out of the bag too many
people are talking about it
in brennan in his in his in his
infinite wisdom infinite wisdom thank
you mike in his infinite wisdom decided
rogan probably wants us to go away i
know what i'll do
i'll talk about it some more i'll talk
about it some more
so he decided to go on his below the
belt and he explained and of course i'm
paraphrasing here
that sling and dick or slang and dick
whichever way you want to say it
him and his buddies mean like doing well
in life doing
good in life crushing it crushing it
even though again of course the question
was i'm trying to have sex but i'm a
bald guy
you know it was specifically a question
about
i'm going bald and women will desire me
less that was
right basis for the entire thing right
and then imagine getting annoyed at the
audience you're the [ __ ] up one for
your mind going there
so on the kill tony uh
podcast live stream whatever you want to
call it uh
well mike you explained this when they
had a comic up there if you want to set
this one up for us
so kill tony you know they bring a lot
of these comics on that
they're open micros and then they make
fun of them and stuff like that whatever
and there's always a panel with with uh
with an established act in there so uh
the open micros generally speaking they
are open micros but they're open
micros that have been doing open mics
they're around they're doing the ice
house they're doing the comedy store
they're doing that
lac that whole yale yeah um
so they kind of have an idea of what's
going on in these people so uh the other
night
kill tony had doug benson on as their
guest
doug benson probably said four words was
it we and they were all weed
at one point that's all i heard from it
was yeah at one point
he seemed like he just seemed like he
was all [ __ ] up so anyway so who are
the people on this panel one's doug
benson
one is doug benson uh one is obviously
tony hinchcliffe right
tony hinchcliffe brian redman of course
ryan redband uh-huh yeah and then that
uh old jamie is what you guys call him
the young blonde lady there now who's
the young blonde lady her name is
ally god [ __ ] what's ali makovsky
you know i just saw that at autofill
because you've already stunned the
research
ally mccaughey so i panicked yeah i was
looking up last night forever i want to
be ready for the show
allie what ally makovsky ali it was
going to autofocus so aly mccoskey
uh is one of the women sitting there at
the table and i guess she's she's opened
for rogan before am i correct by saying
that she's touring with rogue internally
she's his opening
oh she's rogan's opener right now i got
it
okay and uh well
things got a little weird here okay so
let's play the first clip and that
the person talking that you're hearing
is the open micro that's talking to the
panel
correct uh the open micro is the puerto
rican trick here
yeah all right i packed it i backed up
just a little bit oh my god
i i like when women fight can i place
bet now
lorena is that your first time doing
stand-up comedy
talking like tony hitchcock but like on
purpose
irena he's hard to listen to it's tough
right yeah
were the other times in puerto rico or
wait no you said you've lived here for
what 10 years like 10 years and i
started recently yeah oh awesome and you
came straight from puerto rico to l.a
yes that's an interesting trip what made
you come straight here instead of
florida like the rest of them
um i wanted the american dream i wanted
to become
sophia vergara and all that [ __ ] so
[ __ ] yeah yeah
so i'm still not even close to that [ __ ]
but
yeah you know the old story about how
sofia vergara started in stand-up comedy
now you talk [ __ ] with me damn these
two are
you talking to me definitely puerto
ricans you did not
talk the entire show and now she's
talking
let's talk about racism let's races
races like i did not hear her
once and now she suits up puerto rican
and it's like oh my god mommy
it's probably harder than fixing your
hair in the bathroom when i was talking
no no i never saw you okay fine yeah
whatever makes you happy joe rogan is
[ __ ] hot i want to [ __ ] him
so that was the first uh
that was the first one somebody sent
this to me
joe rogan's hot and i want to [ __ ] him
too so that was the first one
and that was the first time i was like
somebody sent this to me last night
right at the end of night wave and i was
like this i was like guys well take care
we're gonna see you tomorrow
i just froze and i'm like oh no this is
spicy
uh so this was the only clip i saw last
night
and then i saw the reddit thread i
followed up after the show i'm like i
gotta get this ready for revenge of the
sis
so it's reading the thread and uh i see
people talking about
um on reddit like is this
true like what's this [ __ ] calling out
is this alley mikowski the one that he's
been [ __ ] whatever
so i thought it was it ended there
well turns out uh that
there it continued all right let's see
yeah trying to find my bottle
um and i saw a mole and yeah
and i got it checked and it was cancer
heck yeah
yeah girl oh ellie's got a mic what do
you got anything oh my god
no nothing just i feel like i i've never
seen by the way i want to pause pause
you'd already see she's pissed oh yeah
here's what
you you want you want to know my theory
i this is my theory of course
again guys this is my theory i have no
idea what really happened
i have a feeling that this uh what's her
name ali makowsky
um makovsky mikowski sorry ali makovsky
probably knows this girl from before
this because they probably do
open mics together or you know [ __ ]
came up through doom comedy together at
the same place right
that would not know like i didn't think
they were they know they know each other
professionally
they've been at show like they've been
at little things and they think they
don't like
each other it could be yeah right well i
don't know if they don't like each other
or i don't know if it was one of those
things one of them's puerto rican was
okay so they probably don't like each
other but women puerto rican women
but i think if they don't like each
other it's one of those they don't like
each other
but are courteous to each other when
they talk and i think at some point
and this is my guess that maybe i'm
wrong and look i could 100
concede that maybe rogan is not [ __ ]
this ally mccoskey
sure yeah maybe he's not he might not he
might not be
but this feels to me like one of those
things when you go
hey man between me and you to try to
one-up her
[ __ ] joe rogan the other night i [ __ ]
you wrong
and that's like well and that's why i'm
opening the forum like something like
that and now she's like oh yeah well you
like you [ __ ] your rogan so
i don't even no i don't think she said
anything to her about it i think it's
a rumor this is a thing that's kind of
just
known in that scene i think i think this
is
whether it's true or not is something
that's been getting passed around
right and it's established now that it
at least among it's the consensus is
that they're [ __ ]
so it gets around and the open mic the
open micros are the worst because
they're the ones that are most bitter so
they're like very [ __ ]
oh you'd be opening for rogue and i'm
[ __ ] better they put what's the [ __ ]
this
you know what i mean that's where all
that [ __ ] starts to fester so it's out
there
um probably in that scene and this [ __ ]
has heard that before and and nailed her
all right so let's
have more joy when she mentions the fact
that she had cancer it just
you just keep smiling ear to ear every
time she brings it up
like you're the one that like put it on
her leg or something like that
and who are the two guys behind her
dressed like the beastie boys
the surviving beastie uh that's the band
oh they're all comedians themselves got
it the guy with the saxophone
is actually jeremiah watkins i've
mentioned him before he is
legitimately probably the only funny one
in that whole song okay
jeremiah watkins is next level funny and
uh it's a shame because he's kind of
like just
clean hinge clips [ __ ] boy like mermaid
boy for sarah weinstein but he's way
funnier than any of the people on this
stage
smiling ear to ear every time she brings
it up like you're the one that like put
it on her leg or something like that
no it's really sad
it's sad that you survived
she's just having fun no no totally i'll
give it to her i mean
she's with joe rogan i can't compete
with that so
twice now that's twice now that's twice
now
you feel the awkward energy i feel i had
to stretch
royce i had to stretch do you feel the i
had to stretch
the awkward did you see me stretching
the awkward
did you see the stretch i would be
[ __ ] bro by the way if that were me
and this were my uh potential
indiscretions being brought up
i would be furious right now especially
if you're touring with this poor person
currently so then people start going oh
that makes sense you know they're
[ __ ] on the road you know what i mean
on the road they're [ __ ]
like if i were married i wouldn't have a
female opener period
it's just nothing that probably would
never have a female opener anyway
because i want to have a good opener
right um but yeah but you don't want to
be too good a i wouldn't have a female
opener and if i did it would be like a
it would be like a rebel wilson looking
[ __ ] you know what i mean like a
melissa mccarthy looking
right monique an actual funny woman yeah
yeah but it wouldn't be
like i wouldn't if i were married and i
had a stepdaughter and all that i
wouldn't be touring with that because
you'd be like yeah he's [ __ ] her
like even and again i'm not saying
because oh yeah what you were
why don't you just not cheat on your
wife how about you just
sure you're right that it but i wouldn't
want to open up
the door to any sort of bitter open
micros being like
they're [ __ ] you know what i mean
like i wouldn't want i'd be like no i
just can't tour with you because i'm a
married guy and
you can understand how this would look
right you know we're booking hotels
together
it's just never in the history of a man
and a woman
uh both being successful and attractive
and working around each other in the
history of that
has there not been rumors in innuendo so
to spare my wife and kids that
i just forget look why don't you just
tour with tony hinchcliffe or brian
right why don't you grab jeremiah
watkins that guy's hilarious
[Laughter]
she's not happy look look look she's not
happy
look at that face she was she wasn't
happy the first time because she was
making jokes about being happy
that she you know did you know was said
she didn't die of cancer
she was pissed after the first one the
second one it's like
okay dude now you yeah that's the first
one she was already losing her composure
and then the second one it was like now
you're
pushing it